fin hasta ahora les tras solamente se ha
tenido que dirigir realmente a los
miembros de su partido conservador que
finalmente votaron por ella en su
mayoría ya partir de hoy de ahora y hace
tiene que dirigir a todo el pueblo
británico sí y obviamente hay hay temas
muy agentes el tema de la inflación el
tema de los precios de la energía que es
un tema muy muy grave para muchos
hogares en todo el país y en las
diferentes partes del terreno nio yo
creo que ella en este discurso
lo que hizo fue en realizar un par de
puntos pero casi no nos dio ninguna
información muy específica por ejemplo
todo el tema de la energía todavía no
nos queda claro y ahora tiene unos pocos
días digamos hasta el jueves quizás
hasta el viernes para realmente
especificar sus políticas públicas para
que no solamente los votantes sino
también los mercados financieros sepan
exactamente cómo este nuevo gobierno
británico
a asumir esta responsabilidad
para poner en contexto a la audiencia
ella sigue teniendo el reino unido
continúa con un mandato del partido
conservador cuál ha sido el balance de
estos 12 años de esos cuatro gobiernos
cuatro administraciones del partido
conservador en reino unido
bueno respecto a un tema que el extras
también acaba de mencionar la prima de
mejores salarios por ejemplo es lo que
ha hecho el partido conservador en los
últimos 12 años ha sido realmente poco
solamente se puede tener salarios más
altos si hay un crecimiento real de la
productividad de la economía y los
conservadores realmente en los últimos
dos años por ejemplo no han logrado eso
entonces falta de innovaciones falta de
inversión en las infraestructuras en
educación
como muy muy amplia entonces esos son
temas que el estrés ahora mismo
realmente tiene que hablar y tiene que
formular esas esas políticas públicas
con algo más específico sobre todo
profesor respecto a la guerra en ucrania
ya anticipábamos q a través de su
ministerio de exteriores que no
esperaban que hubiera una mejora en las
relaciones con londres con la llegada de
lis atrás que se puede esperar de esta
nueva agenda tan importante que es para
reino unido que es la guerra en ucrania
bueno hasta ahora el
disfraz ha sido bastante elige elige
vender con vladimir putin y no realmente
ha buscado en un acercamiento no ha
buscado el diálogo con rusia
ahora lo que esperamos realmente es que
ya
siguen con esta actitud bastante
fuerte o si ahora como primera ministra
entre a un discurso o en un diálogo con
rusia quizás en unidad con eeuu o con
varios países en europa debido a esta
situación muy difícil de la inflación y
del tema energético
y yo creo que en algún momento pronto
también la prensa británica y algunos
votantes van a preguntar por qué el
gobierno británico transfiere miles de
millones de libras esterlinas cada mes a
ucrania mientras en el mismo reino unido
la gente está sufriendo eso es una
pregunta muy importante que todavía no
ha surgido mucho pero seguramente en
unas semanas está nuestra pregunta va a
surgir y esta pregunta hay que abordarla
desde el gobierno